hey this is presto Walker you play a
dice rolling game where you can win
money you roll a fair six-sided dice you
could stop in earn the value of the roll
in dollars or you can roll again if you
roll again the same rules apply you can
stop and earn the value of the roll or
you can roll again if you choose to roll
a third time you will earn the value of
the roll in the game ends how should you
play this game to earn the most money on
average and how much money can you earn
in other words what is the expected
value of this game I want to thank James
M for sending me a problem which
inspired this video and before I get to
the countdown and the solution I want to
mention one point whenever I make a
video about rolling a dice someone
always emails me or leaves a comment
that dice is the plural and die is the
singular so let me just read from the
Oxford dictionary's the usage of the
word dice historically dice is the
plural of die but in modern Standard
English dice is both the singular and
the plural throw the dice could mean a
reference to either one or more than one
dice so it is perfectly correct to say
you roll a fair six-sided dice with that
in mind and with these rules of the game
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution
so here's one way that the game could
play out on your very first roll you
could get any of the six numbers from
one to six let's suppose you get the
number two you decide that's too low of
a value so you choose that you want to
roll again so then you could get any of
the six possibilities and let's suppose
you get the number three you decide that
three is too low of a value so you
decide to roll again and on the third
roll you could get any of the six
possibilities let's suppose you get
lucky and you get a five so you'll get
paid five dollars the question is how
should we play this game how do we know
when we should roll again versus when we
should just stop to figure that out we
need to think ahead and analyze
backwards so if you roll for the third
time what is your average payout in
other words let's not consider the first
two rolls of the game let's just focus
on the third roll and ask if we got to
the third roll what would our average
payout be well if we just focus on this
what would the value be let's write VI
to be the value of the game before roll
I on the third roll the dice shows each
number from 1 to 6 with equal chance so
V 3 will be the average of these numbers
which equals 3 point 5 so we know that
if we get to the third roll we can
expect an average payout of 3 point 5
therefore we can replace this entire
diagram of the third roll with just one
value of the average payout of 3.5 what
that allows us to do is then think
backwards to the second roll knowing the
third roll gives an average of 3.5 how
should we play the second roll but let's
think about this logically
if you get a role that's larger than 3.5
it would make sense to stop and take the
larger payout because rather than
getting an average of 3.5 we're actually
getting something more than 3.5 so if we
roll a four five or six we should stop
at the second role on the other hand if
we roll less than 3.5 we should not stop
and accept this lower value we should
instead continue to the third role where
we get an average of 3.5 so if we get
one two or three it would make sense to
roll again because rather than getting
the smaller value we would get an
average of 3.5 on the third role now if
we stop we will get the value of that
role so we would either get a four or
five or six with equal chance so the
average when we stop will be the average
of four five and six which is five so
now we can figure out the value of the
second role based on these possibilities
well either get a four five and six and
we'll stop and get our average payout
from there or we'll get a one two or
three and we'll roll again and get the
average payout of the third role so half
the time or three six of the time we'll
get an average payout of five because
we've stopped and the other 3/6 or 1/2
the time will roll to the third and get
an average payout of 3.5 so the value in
the second role is the average of these
possibilities which equals 4.25 so now
what can we do well we need to analyze
backwards one more time to the first
role we can do the same sort of
calculation we can replace the entire
possibility of a second role by v2
equals 4.25 now let's think about the
first role knowing that the second role
can give us an average of 4.25 how
should we play the first role just like
before we analyzes logically if we get a
role
that's larger than this average payout
4.25 it would make sense to stop and
take the larger payout in this case this
would be for the rolls five and six
furthermore if we get a roll that's
smaller than the average payout of 4.25
you should not stop and instead continue
to the second roll where you could get
that average payout of 4.25 so if you
roll a one two three or four you would
want to roll again so in those cases you
would not accept the lower value you
would get the average payout of 4.25 by
rolling again if we were to stop we
would get an average payout of five or
six which becomes five point five so now
we can calculate the average value from
before the first roll will either roll a
five or six and stop and get that
expected payout or we'll roll one two
three or four and then we'll decide to
roll again and get the average payout
before the second roll so we can
substitute in those values to sixth or
one third of the time we'll get an
average payout of five point five and
four six or two thirds of the time we'll
get an average payout of four point two
five adding those we get a result of 14
over three which equals four point six
repeating and that's the value to this
game from the first roll so let's think
about this if we were to just roll the
dice a single time we would get an
average of three point five but because
we get up to three rolls and we play
optimally we can actually increase our
average to about four point six seven
and that's an increase of about thirty
three point three percent in winnings so
that's a huge increase in winnings
because we're allowed the option of
rolling a second and third time and we
decide to roll optimally did you figure
it out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math you can catch me on my
blog mind your decisions if you like
this video you can check out my books
which are linked in the video
description
you can support me on patreon if you
have a suggestion you can email me my
email address is pressure and mind your
decisions comm you can also catch me on
social media either at mind your
decisions or at pressure Walker
depending on the site